yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're taking a deep dive into army
of the dead's twist ending
the alien origins of the undead secret
cyborg zombies and a second
mind-bending twist you might have missed
many thanks to state of survival for
sponsoring this video
spoilers ahead so take care army of the
dead kicks off with a high octane
sequence that reveals how the zombie
apocalypse started
gatekeeper this is mother ship the four
horsemen are on the gallop
you are a go to open the stable door
this mothership
mention is the first tease among many
that zack snyder deliberately wanted to
make to the extraterrestrial origins of
the zombies
there's also the fact that the payload
the convoy is transporting is exiting
area 51. the classified u.s air force
facility in nevada that's routinely
associated with ufo conspiracy theories
in both pop culture and real life
playing on this two bright white orbs
can be seen in the sky
and they zoom off in the direction of
the convoy as the journey begins
all right i'll say it it's an alien the
alien origins of this apocalypse may
also be a nod to george romero's 1968
genre defining knight of the living dead
in that film scientists theorized that
the zombie outbreak could have been
caused when nasa shot down
explore a satellite to venus that upon
its return to earth was found to be
carrying an unusually high level of
radiation
the otherworldly nature of army of the
dead zombies is also hinted at in the
name of the hotel where they take refuge
in vegas the olympus
a reference to mount olympus which in
greek mythology was considered a
heavenly threshold and the seat of the
gods
and they're all led by the original
alpha who created them
zeus named after the statue of the king
of the gods whose statue he sees when he
arrives in vegas
the film's official press notes reveal
that zeus's backstory is depicted on the
side of the olympus hotel
the circular object in the middle with
light emanating from it with men and
animals looking on
may be hinting at the arrival of a ufo
on earth that has unleashed some
kind of zombie virus alternately it
might be pointing to secret government
experiments on aliens or alien mata with
the intention of creating a new type of
warrior
after all we do know that martin's
secret mission was to capture a zombie
head for his boss tanaka who was in turn
covertly working with the us military
snyder has talked about giving the
zombies a kind of higher consciousness
than we normally see and then getting
the audience to feel sympathy with or
connect to the zombies which is why he
has scenes where they nuzzle each other
to reaffirm their emotional bonds
on top of that we see these zombies
communicating with each other and
like humans they have a social hierarchy
with distinctions between
alphas and shamblers they even have
rules and norms
that people like lily the coyote have
been able to learn which is why she
offers up the abusive birth as a
sacrifice to them in return for a
limited amount of freedom to move around
the city
smarter they're faster they're organized
they won't mind us poking around
so long as we play by their rules also
next to the human hybrid figure in the
picture
is what looks like a woman in some kind
of luminescent bubble
i wonder whether this is referencing
zeus's zombie queen and the moment of
her baby's conception
perhaps even an allusion to it being
some kind of religious or spiritual
experience such as the virgin mary's
visitation by the holy spirit
this ability for zombies to become
pregnant similar to humans is intriguing
and snyder says he had the idea from the
beginning that these zombies were going
to embody an evolution on their way to
becoming something else
not stagnant like the zombies were used
to by the way snyder also touched on the
theme of zombie babies in his first
undead flick dawn of the dead although
he said that the two films aren't
connected and of course the zombie baby
in that movie was conceived when its
parents were both still humans unlike
this latest film
snyder's also said that the ambiguity
surrounding the zombie origins in army
of the dead will be explored further in
the upcoming netflix animated prequel
series last vegas in which he teases
that we'll get to see zombies in space
another zombie detail that you might
have missed as you can only see them at
very brief moments in the movie is the
existence of what appear to be robot or
cyborg zombies the clearest example
you'll see comes when the team are
fighting their way through the casino
floor and raul shoots a zombie in the
head revealing a glowing blue eye and
metal skull underneath
you can also see another zombie with two
glowing blue eyes and the crowd at the
olympus as zeus enters with the corpse
of his zombie queen
snyder has said this is supposed to hint
at two possibilities
first that the government could have
placed them among the zombies to monitor
them
or second that they're technology from
another world
although zeus and all the zombies he
created are wiped out when the
government nukes vegas the twist at the
end is that one of his fight victims van
der rohe did survive thanks to being
enclosed inside the exceptionally strong
safe
underground when the nuclear bomb went
off with randaro discovering his
infected just as he's about to touch
down in mexico city the zombie outbreak
looks set to spread to mexico and likely
beyond however van der rohe's fate was
predicted in a subtle way right from the
beginning and i'm going to dive deep
into that
plus explain the mind-bending second
twist you might have missed
right after thanking this video sponsor
state of survival
status survival is a zombie-themed
survival strategy game available
completely free to download on both ios
and
android and thanks to an awesome new
crossover event with amc as the walking
dead you can now play the game as daryl
dixon
the game is set in the aftermath of a
deadly disaster where you can form
alliances with other players or build
and grow your own settlement solo to
defend yourself against the zombie
hordes
you'll need to build up your skills in
the game and recruit other heroes so you
can go up against the evil company
gigacorp which unleash the zombie
catastrophe on the world
the game has tons of rewards for
dedicated players and some great events
like oasis
guests a daily quiz about the walking
dead and state of survival where you can
win prizes including amazon gift cards
walking dead fans will also love the twd
easter eggs hidden in every corner of
the game
and you can collect these by completing
different tasks or exchanging them with
friends
the game is full of many cool twists and
turns and features multiple game modes
so you'll never get bored
for a limited time you can grab a
completely free starter pack by using my
creator code flix
sos so download state of survival for
free via the link below
and use code flix sos for an awesome set
of starter awards
okay so the clue that van der rohe would
become the last zombie survivor of the
vegas outbreak was signaled via the
amiga symbol on his chest which likely
has several meanings
first of all given he's a philosophy
graduate van der rohe may be a member of
the amiga sci-fi fraternity who are
known to sometimes mark their skin with
the amiga symbol
amiga is also the last letter in the
greek alphabet and given the abundance
of grecian references in the movie it's
a pointer to van der rohe ending up as a
final zombie who survives this story
zeus was of course the first alpha
zombie and alpha is the first letter in
the greek
alphabet and in the apocalyptic book of
revelation the term alpha and amiga is
also used as a title for god
in addition to symbolizing endings amiga
can also symbolize a great step forward
a hint perhaps that the zombie van dero
will turn into could be an even
stronger or more advanced creation than
zeus after all despite the protection
from the safe
it's possible some radiation from the
atomic bomb leaked in and affected the
way the zombie bite infected him
and is that what he was hinting at when
he quoted joseph campbell
it is by going down into the abyss where
we recover the treasures of life where
you stumble
there lies your treasure to the ironic
twist of the unknown
any weird atomic related powers van der
rohe might have gained could also be a
possible explanation for how he managed
to survive any ill effects from the bike
for so long that he was able to walk out
of vegas drive to utah and
charge her a private plane all before
turning into a zombie
the gerta damarang safe may also be the
source for secret second twist in the
movie
first of all its name is significant
because it's not only the last cycle in
wagner's epic opera but it's also the
german translation of the old norse
phrase ragnarok aka the twilight of the
gods
in norse mythology ragnarok is a
cataclysmic event leading to the death
of many gods and the renewal of the
earth
if i can open it it will be either
destruction
or renewal death or rebirth
as heavy brother but i dig it
that line from dieter foreshadows his
death at the hands of zeus and his
zombies when he closes the vault's door
on van der rohe who by contrast will be
figuratively reborn when he emerges
and when scott and maria visit dieter to
ask him whether he'll be able to crack
the safe his answer reveals a clue to a
potential second twist in the movie
it's a doorway to another realm my
friends and providence has brought you
to me
we go through it together that line may
explain a puzzling moment later outside
the vault when dieter discovers the
remains of another team
there's another team of grave robbers is
it another team or is it us dieter
i mean look at him it's us it could be
us in another timeline
and we're caught in some infinite loop
of fighting and dying fighting and dying
fighting and dying and tanaka
puppet master the devil god and we
you me goose and the rest of the team
simply poland
in some perverse play where we're
destined to repeat our failures
and finally in some mind-bending
ironic reveal it all begins again
if you look closely at the skeletons
they really do seem to be wearing the
same items the current crew have been
wearing throughout the mission
the scots red bandana maria's kia
necklace and the colorful shirt and
metal chains that peters wears
what's even more strange is that in this
movie maria is the only
one of those three who dies in the area
by the vault
scott and peters both die after the
helicopter crashes outside vegas
it's a very uncanny moment when you
consider what van der rohe says about a
timeline loop however dieter's earlier
reference of the volt being like a
doorway to another realm
makes me think a potential explanation
is that when van der rohe emerges from
the safe and the rubble in vegas the
atomic blast has somehow made him turn
up in an alternate timeline
it's pretty crazy but with the placement
of these skeletons and van der rohe's
weird time loop monologue the movie
seems to want to suggest that there
could be some strange
timeline shenanigans going on and it
might not be a complete coincidence that
it was inside the vault where schneider
decided to include a justice league
snyder cut easter egg
the canisters on the shelf to the left
of the safe store hold the actual reels
of footage that snyder film for justice
league
and spoiler alert in snyder's version of
that movie the flash uses time reversal
as a crucial plot point to reverse
darkseid's mother box apocalypse
so could snyder be using the vault as a
kind of magical plot device to create
multiple timelines in an army of the
dead multiverse
of course van der rohe's mention of an
infinite loop of fighting and dying
maybe hyperbole on his part given he
studied philosophy
and more of a foreshadowing of how his
own survival and infection means that
although the nuke should have ended the
apocalypse for good the zombie plague
will carry on
that doesn't explain though where the
skeletons with the crew's clothing came
from unless that's some elaborate ruse
by tanaka for example given he'd
apparently already sent teams into the
city before and given the fact he also
withheld the real purpose of the mission
let me know what you think in the
comments below so what did you think of
army of the dead and if you enjoyed this
a thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated
coming up will be videos on lucifer
cruella and the conjuring 3.
so tap left my next video or tap right
for something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers